hervé morin le président du nouveau
centre est l'invité de preuves par 3
bonsoir hervé morin et vous êtes là un
moment très opportun évidemment au
moment où les cartes sont rebattues au
centre en vue de la présidentielle
évidemment sur vos ciel avec moi pour
vous interroger tout à l'heure pierre
rocky colis de l' agence france-presse
notre partenaire pour ce rendez vous
hebdomadaire de public sénat et puis
perrine tarneaud de public sénat
le forfait de jean-louis borloo ouvre le
chemin au candidat naturel du centre
mais ça n'est pas vous hein c'est quand
même plutôt françois bayrou
de l'avis unanime des commentateurs vous
allez voir leurs ventes souvent monsieur
vous ne pourrez aussi vous politique
parce que les coups commencent à
pleuvoir un sûr vous allez y compris
d'ailleurs dans votre proximité
immédiate enfin on verra sans retenue
car c'est toujours chez ses amis qu'on a
les meilleurs soutiens politiques
particulièrement mais vous êtes
également comme françois bayrou qui n'a
pas encore officiellement annoncé sa
candidature c'est tout comme
vous êtes également très déterminé en
mettant en avant pour l'instant votre
projet la candidature suivra
hier ministre de nicolas sarkozy demain
candidat contre nicolas sarkozy en tous
les cas vos détracteurs et pas seulement
les commentateurs de la presse pointe
cette contradiction qui vise au
également gens lui font leur revenir
bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr on
en parlera un petit peu plus tard mais
je note que vous ne retenez pas vos
coûts d'ores et déjà contre nicolas
sarkozy vous réclamez par exemple une
république irréprochable elle ne l'est
pas ou il ne l'est plus depuis 2007
c'était un des engagements de la
campagne de nicolas sarkozy qui n'a pas
été tenue
s'il ya au moins un échec durant ce
quinquennat c'est cette question là tant
dans les procédures de nomination dans
les choix ou certaines nominations ou
tentative de nomination était pour le
moins un peu surprenante plus précis je
prenais un exemple quand
vous décidez que le patron de veolia
devient patron d'edf sans qu'il soit
obligé de démissionner c'est à peu près
contraire à toutes les règles qui
peuvent exister en matière de
gouvernance des entreprises
est ce que votre collègue était la mieux
placée pour devenir patron de
l'établissement public de versailles
on pourrait multiplier à l'infini tel ou
tel nommé conseiller économique et
social pour dégager la place du canton
de levallois nord ou levallois sud hauts
est-ce que c'est d'équilibrer la
république est en cause
oui je pense qu'il y a là une
problématique d'exemplarité de 2,2
message adressé aux français
est ce que dans cette période difficile
l'état ne doit pas être plus exemplaire
que les autres c'est ça le vrai sujet et
cette exemplarité là elle doit devenir à
l'aune de ce qui peut exister dans les
autres pays notamment dans les pays du
nord de l'europe et pour cela
moi je souhaite au lendemain de
l'élection présidentielle un référendum
j'ai clairement indiqué ce que devrait
contenir pour moi ce référendum
un référendum dans le rap ce serait
c'est un référendum avec cinq ou six
dispositions
le premier la promenade le premier
élément c'est le cumul de mandats je
suis pour la suppression du cumul des
mandats je vous expliquerai pourquoi ça
se fait par et faire dans tout ça le
deuxième élément c'est le cumul des
fonctions entre ministres et mandats
locaux il faut y mettre fin et certaines
autres fonctions comme trésorier de
parti
le troisième sujet c'est toute la
question des conflits d'intérêt entre la
politique et le privé je pense par
exemple qu'on ne peut pas être
parlementaire et gérant d'une société
ayant régulièrement des commandes avec
les tables qu'on ne peut pas être avocat
d'affaires et être parlementaire parce
que même si vous prenez toutes les
précautions un jour ou l'autre vous
serez rattrapé par un vote
on dira mais c'est parce que vous avez
tel ou tel client je souhaite enfin
qu'il y est très clairement des
dispositions qui permettent de mettre
fin selon moi à une des grandes
bizarreries de la démocratie française
qui est la détention d
société de presse les sociétés de presse
ne doivent pas être détenus par des
entreprises qui elles aussi ont des
intérêts avec l'état pourquoi pas
référendum parce que hein
il y aurait traversé à l'expression
d'une vraie volonté ont saisi le peuple
français
et la deuxième chose c'est que on sait
bien le poids colossal du lobby des élus
locaux dans le parlement
on a vu cette réforme des collectivités
locales totalement ratée parce que
députés et sénateurs sont des cumulards
bon je suis et donc il faut pour
notamment le cumul des mandats il faut
que ce soit soumis au peuple pour qu'on
puisse le faire sans que le gouvernement
soit obligé de reculer pas vous mettre
en règle avec vos propres exigent non
vous voyez regarder un autre nom pour
une raison très simple vous en avez vous
avez quelqu'un qui est pris qui est
candidat à la primaire du ps qu'arnaud
montebourg qui a été un des grands
fondeurs qu'il allait abandonner
nationale
pourquoi at il décidé d'avoir un mandat
local parce que vous avez besoin d'être
en situation d'égalité au moment d'une
campagne électorale
moi j'ai le président du conseil général
contre moi par exemple qui est
constamment en train de distribuer des
subventions etc etc et dont vous êtes
obligés d'avoir des radars quand il faut
la même règle pour tous et il faut
l'imposer oil corp bon alors quand vous
avez été ministre vous avez souffert de
ces entorses à la neutralité
républicaine que vous dénoncez
aujourd'hui on vous a pas entendu ou il
ment fin on n'est pas obligé quand vous
êtes ministre vous pouvez vous exprimer
sans pour autant exprimé par la voix de
la presse vous pouvez aussi faire part
d'un certain nombre de doutes sur
l'argile arriver directement en tête à
tête avec le chef de l'état de faire par
le centre d'interrogation bon dernière
affaire qui bruissent celle enquête qui
aurait été commandée par la police sur
la compagne de françois hollande la
journaliste politique valérie
trierweiler est ce que ça vous paraît
crédible sachant que claude guéant dit
je serais indigné
c'est cela était avéré on peut pas
imaginer que en permanence les chefs de
la police prennent des décisions sans en
référer au pouvoir politique donc ce que
je souhaite c'est que nos mii enquête
soit menée
éventuellement que la magistrature soit
saisie si on a des éléments de preuve et
que on aille jusqu'au bout de l'enquète
pour savoir la vérité mais ça fait
beaucoup
les écoutes sur les sources des
journalistes
alors qu'on vient de voter une loi ou
qu'on est sur le point de la beauté
cette affaire là aussi il faut que les
responsabilités soient clairement tiré
bien sûr vous considérez comme jean
louis borloo que les temps sont troublés
c'était une expression qu'il a utilisée
ouais elle étend pas c'est une période
dans laquelle les français ont forcément
des haut-le-coeur quand vous avez ces
successions d'affaires
quand vous avez le sentiment que la
démocratie française ne sort pas de ses
mauvaises habitudes qui pourtant datait
des années 80 ou 90 et dont on avait dit
qu'elle était terminée puisqu'il y avait
désormais des lois sur le financement de
la vie politique
c'est vrai que tout ça n'est pas bon
pour le décor entre j'ajoute j'ajoute
pour avoir fait deux campagnes
électorales auprès de françois bayrou
qu'on peut en plus faire des campagnes
politiques sans avoir d'espèces sans
avoir de valises que tout ça peut se
faire avec des moyens légaux régulier
sans que vous n'ayez le sentiment de
pouvoir développer votre argumentation
très bien à propos des affaires
justement notamment l' affaire karachi
et puis celle qui est révélé aujourd'hui
a confirmé par l'express sur cette
enquête policière concernant la compagne
de françois hollande votre collègue
député ump eric ciotti dénonce lui les
magistrats qui se détournent et qui
détourne même leur charge
en fait il les accuse d'avoir des
arrières pensées politiques pensent que
ça je trouve est le cas je pense que ça
n'est pas sain de ne pas respecter le
principe de séparation des pouvoirs
je pense que ça ne sert personne entaché
les institutions entaché la justice ça
ne sert certainement pas la république
et la démocratie c'est très clair
l'une des raisons qui n'a pas forcément
mises en avant mais
renoncement de jean louis borloo c'est
justement la crainte d'une campagne
violente
est ce que pour vous cette campagne
s'annonce plus dure que les autres
est-ce que ce climat ces craintes
pourraient vous faire reculer demain non
moi ça me fera pas reculer d'une part
parce que très franchement et il faudra
chercher longtemps avant de pouvoir me
salir sur sur ce genre de sujet et et
deuxièmement je pense que c'est
inévitable et que les français savent
tirer trier tous acquis une victoire
inévitable
les coups bas les rumeurs le net en plus
désormais s'y prête beaucoup
tout ça est inévitable toutes les
campagnes électorales se font comme cela
quand elles sont locales elles se font
sur des rumeurs locales quand elles sont
nationales elles se font sur des rumeurs
national avec tout voilà tous les coups
possibles vous banalisez alors c'est ce
drôle de travers politique la campagne
je pense là en revanche que toutes les
démocraties sont quand même rythme après
bien couverts constaté comme nous tous
que l'ump a très vite tendu la main à
jean-louis borloo pour se réjouir de son
abandon et parce que pour vous c'est
forcément une bonne nouvelle pour
nicolas sarkozy
je pense que l'idée qu' il n'y ait pas
de candidature centriste pour faciliter
la vie nicolas sarkozy c'est une erreur
absolue au moment au moment où la france
est face à autant de difficultés il faut
un choix nouveau
moi je veux incarner à la fois le
renouveau de la vie politique et la
modernité de la vie politique
qui peut croire un seul instant que
c'est en bâillonnant le suffrage
universel qu'on peut espérer faire
gagner quelqu'un ça ne marche pas comme
ça
au moment où les français sont appelés à
décider de leur destin pour cinq ans on
voudrait leur dire écoutez c'est fromage
ou dessert en quelque sorte c'est ps ou
ump bien moi je dis qu'il y à une offre
politique nouvelle à inventer à mettre
en oeuvre à présenter aux français
j'ai parlé de la république
irréprochable tout à l'heure je pourrais
évoquer la question de la dette et de
l'endettement du pays
pour évoquer comment redonner à la
france la performance économique et la
croissance puisque j'ai présenté mes
propositions économiques à trois mois
comment fait-on pour faire en sorte que
on sait ce suicide collectif que
représentent ces deux cent mille jeunes
qui chaque année sont en situation
d'illettrisme
bref sur tous ces sujets nous devons
inventer un projet politique
radicalement nouveau et face à ça on
vous dit mais surtout conserver les
mêmes garder les mêmes
et bien moi ça n'est pas d'imposition
j'ajoute enfin que pour être clair
j'ajoute enfin attendez j'ajoute enfin
pour les les 15 à 20 % de français qui
votent centre centre droit à chaque
élection qu'est ce qu'on leur dit à cela
vous rendez vous restez à la maison on
leur dit exprimez vous exprimer votre
mécontentement éventuel en votant marine
le pen
peut-il ce sont vous n'avez pas d'autre
choix monsieur bayrou je vous rappelle
mais monsieur bayrou et sur une
stratégie politique différente avec
monsieur bayrou une stratégie politique
où ils auront nous ressert une nouvelle
fois la même soupe je serai au second
tour et donc ne me demandez pas ce que
je ferai au soir du premier tour
moi je pense que la démocratie nécessite
la clarté et la clarté
on sait que venus ralliement à nicolas
sarkozy alors c'est là où votre votre
mot et méprisant et non pas son
ralliement qu'il vous déplaît oui qui me
déplaît parce qu'il s'agit pas d'un
ralliement d'un menu de quoi il s'agit
de dire très clairement que notre
soutien au second tour et conditionner
un contrat de législature est
conditionnée à un certain nombre de
propositions qui seront retenues par le
candidat du second tour c'est
radicalement différente
c'est exactement le modèle de toutes les
démocraties européennes chacun présente
son projet politique au premier tour et
ensuite au second tour si je puis dire
ou au moment de la formation d'une
majorité au parlement
eh bien il ya un contrat de gouvernement
avec la législature en tout cas vous
êtes
plus que jamais depuis dimanche sous la
mitraille de l'ump il sonne la charge en
termes assez vive badine morano trouve
que votre candidature serait inutile et
apporterait de la division je vois aussi
que beaucoup d'élus nouveau centre de
votre part tour de votre parti ne vous
suivent pas dans cette aventure vous
allez en général vous me citez toujours
les deux mêmes à qui on le sait roy et
jean christophe lagarde a envie dans six
mois quand même parce qu'il a une
formule quand même terrible a dit
maurice leroy il veut pas troquer un
avant-centre janvier borloo contre un
arrière centre vous c'est pas sympa
enfin en famille politique j'ai entendu
le même maurice leroy m'expliquer tant
de choses
oui oui oui oui je joue également de
soucy j'étais pris dans un groupe
parlementaire
donc ça me permet de comme j'ai eu
beaucoup de mémoire ça me je me rappelle
de ce que les uns et les autres disent
eh bien avant que bayrou soit il dissout
à 15% en descendent alors s'il n'y a pas
d'autres nouveaux centres qui sont
réticents également à l'estadio el
cheikh en soit vous pouvez aussi une
parler de philippe vigier yvan lachaud
charles 2%
nous sommes au sénat jean léonce dupont
hervé mort et catherine morin dessailly
jean paul amoudry tout parlementaire qui
me soutiennent et qui ont qui souhaite
qu'il y ait de cette candidature
centriste à la présidence alors ceux qui
vous suivent et ceux qui hésitent encore
à voir refuse c'est le sujet que nous
présente sandra cerqueira et on en
reparle dans un instant avec bien sûr
pierre roques et kelly camp socialiste
joli conte kitchen les grands
spécialistes du centre un agence france
presse d'abord le leur une enquête de
sandra cirque à l'alliance républicaine
écologiste et sociale pour fédérer les
chapelles du centre droit sauf qu hervé
morin a toujours contesté l'investiture
de borloo pour 2012
au sein de cette alliance après le
forfait de son rival le champ est libre
sa candidature aurait pu couler de
source mais elle ne fait pas rêver grand
monde au sein de l'alliance
à commencer par le président exécutif du
nouveau centre lui même mais qu'il
arrive d
convaincre nos amis et puis après on
verra si cette candidature est valide il
y avait un candidat centriste crédible
issu de nos rangs aujourd'hui je suis
pas très sûr qu'on puisse avoir au sein
de l'alliance quelque chose qui nous
représentons porte les aspirations des
français être au second tour de
présidentielle
les proches de borloo pas très emballé
par la solution morin tous le disent une
candidature 1 % dans les sondages
n'apporterait pas grand-chose au centre
et jean louis borloo avait un
rayonnement et une encore une fois une
visibilité plus grande est je pense une
inadéquation très clairement identifiés
par l'électorat quand encore une fois au
segment qu'incarner jean louis borloo à
sa proximité est son côté humaniste
sociale etc
au modem aussi l'hypothèse mourin fait
franchement sourire on est candidat
quand on a quelque chance de porter le
message le plus loin possible plus fort
le plus haut j'ai pas le sentiment
aujourd'hui que
ce soit morin qui soit en capacité de le
porter certains vont encore plus loin
si hervé morin se déclare il n'ira pas
jusqu'au bout
une position qui aux yeux de certains
n'auraient que pour objectif de négocier
un poste auprès de nicolas sarkozy a
négocié un poste pas simplement négocier
un poste ça m'amuse beaucoup parce que
moi j'ai au moins cette chance là c'est
que j'ai exercé une des plus grandes
fonctions de la république en étant mise
défense fois en trois ans et demi donc
le fantasme de la fonction ministérielle
s'est passé pour moi d'accord alors
pierre aucaigne accueilli avec kirby wii
alors pour soir un mort un mois je
voulais revenir sur l'intervention de
jean-louis borloo de dimanche
vous avez dit comme beaucoup de gens ont
d'ailleurs avoir été surpris par cette
intervention
surpris par la précipitation mais sur le
fond est ce que vous ne vous envisagiez
pas que jean louis borloo pourrait ne
pas aller au bout de cette candidature
témoin j'entendais le la volonté de
france 2 les jean louis borloo 2 de
porter cette candidature
j'exprimais la même volonté voilà je
pense que c'est respectable de d'avoir
fait ce geste là le pire aurait été pour
nous que jean louis continue sur ce
chemin pendant des semaines et un moment
ou un autre nous disent voilà je j'ai
décidé de renoncer
donc c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle que
ça se passe japon en ce moment je pense
que c'est bien que ça se passe
maintenant imaginons que j'avais
toujours indiqué que je prendrai ma
décision fin novembre début décembre
the clash dans métro témoins imaginons
que cette annonce intervienne après que
je ne sois mois prononcée et indiqué que
jean louis borloo et tant mieux placé à
ce moment là dans les sondages ce soit
notre candidat
ça veut dire que on pouvait considérer
que notre affaire était réglé alors jean
louis borloo après j'insiste sur cette
histoire
bon j'écoute les uns les autres que
quelqu'un du modem discussions pas le
mieux placé ça c'est tout à fait naturel
et normal
jean christophe lagarde qui n'a jamais
eu un mot de sympathie et mon milliards
en quatre ans le fasse c'est tout à fait
normal aussi mais le jeu dire quel est
le sens d'un parti politique si c'est si
vous refusez d'aller présenter un projet
politique devant les électeurs si vous
refusez d'affronter le suffrage
universel
quelle peut être la légitimité de
parlementaires d'être présent dans un
hémicycle pour porter un message
politique
quant à aucun moment vous n'avez fronte
et le suffrage universel les porter ce
projet au moment capital que représente
l'élection présidentielle et donc je dis
simplement à mes amis je leur dis si on
considère que la politique a un sens et
si on considère que la politique c'est
tout de même d'abord et avant tout de
porter un projet des valeurs
eh bien on doit accepter le combat
quelle que soit la difficulté du combat
je reconnais très naturellement
alors jean louis borloo une des
explications qu'il a données dimanche
soir c'est qu'il ne voulait pas il
pensait pas être au deuxième tour il ne
voulait pas à porter une candidature de
témoignage il était crédité de 6 à 8%
vous êtes crédité de 2% actuellement est
ce que pour vous c'est une candidature
de témoignage mais attendez monsieur
requêtes chauny s'avoue satisfait le
principe d'une candidature de 6 est bien
c'est qu'avec vous les sondages font les
français français mais c'est pourquoi il
ya des élections approche considérée de
passer de 2 1%
je l'écouté moi j'ai fait j'ai cette
chance là c'est que je suis baigné dans
la vie publique au sens large depuis
longtemps et passionné par la chose
publique
j'ai vu des candidats élus avant même
que les français y votée cet été doit re
balladur j'ai vu des candidats qui
devaient disparaître c'était jacques
chirac
j'ai vu ségolène royal dont on
expliquait que petit ministre délégué à
l'enseignement elle n'était pas en
mesure de pouvoir rivaliser avec
dominique strauss kahn et laurent fabius
aux primaires du ps puis à l'élection
présidentielle
et entendu monsieur rqic au lit je suis
sûr que monsieur grosseur on pourrait
retrouver des bandes entières sur ce
sujet là ses précédentes fonctions
expliqué que françois hollande c'était
fini qu'on en parlait plus que c'était
une histoire du passé qu'il avait échoué
à la tête du parti socialiste
si vous gagnez c'est pour est au 2e tour
vous dit j'y vais pour bien entendu
faire le plus gros score être au second
tour kankan caire j'ai conscience de la
hauteur de la marche
oui mais je pense j'ai essayé
d'expliquer tout à l'heure à michel
grossiord que c'est pas simplement une
candidature de témoignage qu'a traversé
assez l'idée de porter un projet
politique dans lequel vous avez un
certain nombre de propositions qui sont
reprises est tenu dans un engagement qui
s'appelle un contrat de législature par
celui que vous soutenez au second tour
en clair vous vous portez vous apportez
votre soutien sous la condition qu'un
certain nombre des propositions vous
avez fait son retenu par celui et qu'il
faut faire que votre message pas passer
dans l'opinion alors que jean-louis
borloo avait la même démonstration
jusqu'à présent et a renoncé il s'est
rendu compte que ça ne marchait pas mais
pour eux ça ne marchait pas est ce que
vous pouvez conseillez il a conclu que
ça ne marchait pas parce qu'il à y
renoncer
je pense que le côté vous poserez la
question des des raisons de du
renoncement de jean-louis vous avez de
votre explication non mais peut y avoir
des raisons personnelles qui sont
beaucoup plus profondes que tout cela et
qu'ils sont et qu'il faut dire vous
croyez pas aux explications qu'il a
données sur tf1 pour à la division de
familles ont pris jeudi
jésus jeudi qu'il peut y avoir de
multiples facteurs il n'appartient pas
de les analyser parce que je ne sais pas
alors pour aller à la bataille il faut
des il faut des troupes
vous savez que
l'alliance fin les responsables et les
militants de l'alliance ne sont pas tous
convaincus par votre candidature et que
les militants même du nouveau centre ne
sont pas tous en tout cas les cadres du
nouveau centre ne sont pas forcément
tous convaincus par votre candidature
aujourd'hui hervé morin c'est combien de
divisions je devrais j'aurais dû prendre
mon mon téléphone portable et mon ipad
ça faire de publicité et vous faire voir
les centaines de messages que j'ai reçus
a certes ce sont des militants sont des
français voilà mais moi je constate au
sein des parlementaires
nombreux sont ceux qui portent la même
idée que moi alors vous me réservez
toujours les deux mêmes c'est bien mais
au bon récit en clair vous renouvelez
pas beaucoup mais a invité philippe
vigier a invité le président à venir
certes toujours non pas forcément puis
vous est aussi censé représenter
l'alliance et l'alliance c'est jean
marie bockel c'est hervé de charette et
que je sache c'est par exemple nous
entre non mais quoi
forcément j'ai soutien de la candidature
est vivement monsieur rqic au lit je
leur pose simplement cette question que
font que feront ils soutenir nicolas
sarkozy au premier tour
françois bayrou est ce que vous recevez
et que je me pose la question si vous
considérez que vous êtes une famille de
pensée et que vous avez un projet
politique qu'on serre et qu'il faut
qu'ils soient défendues ce que vous
recevez des messages de soutien du côté
de l'ump je ne sais pas si ma de dire
que vous êtes en pleine confusion vous
pouvez peut-être rendre la monnaie de la
pièce ça m'intéresse alors j'ai entendu
dire que vous étiez par contre est
avancé dans cette candidature que vous
aviez déjà je crois 800 signatures
d'élus envisager que vous aviez un local
de des locaux mêmes de campagne repéré
un prêt pour votre campagne où c'est
vrai tout ça use en est où je n'ai pas
l'habitude de mentir monsieur rqic au
lit donc tout ça et exor d'accord donc
c'est bien avancé
l'équipe de champagne aussi gg alors le
siège c'est au jeu ne l'ont pas vous le
dire je passais pas mensonge par
omission
vous avez un siège j'ai voyagé j'ai deux
sièges potentiel est possible qu'ils
sont depuis belle lurette prédéterminé
j'ai jamais rencontrée alors certes
avant la crise bancaire mais le
responsable d'une grande banque
française qui m'avait donné un accord de
principe
voilà et quant aux signatures très
honnêtement c'est pas une question qui
se pose pour le nouveau centre et
l'équipe de campagne déjà constitué l
équipe de campagne vous la verrez mais
quelle impatience l impatience
d'accord vous êtes dans les starting
blocks qu'est ce qui pourrait empêcher
alors hervé morin d'aller au bout de
cette candidature
peu de choses est-ce que vous tendez la
main aux déçus que laisse le président
du parti radical
bien entendu je dis je dis à tout le
monde venez venez rejoignez nous
rejoignons rejoignez moi et faisons
ensemble cette campagne parce que risque
de me répéter vous un parti politique
une famille politique qui refuse d'aller
devant les électeurs c'est une famille
politique qui est appelé à disparaître
vous avez dit que jean-louis borloo a pu
renoncer également pour des raisons
personnelles
un oui mais vous l'avez un peu aidé
aussi fremm qu'on le dit à ce moment-là
pierre avec moi quand même
il découragé il ya eu des moments
difficiles et il leur vécu les tensions
qui voit l'art dernier aux premières
universités la santé c'est ce qu'on lit
vous avez votre part de responsabilité
monsieur riccioli je n'ai jamais fait
mystère de ma volonté de porter ce
message centriste donc au fur et à
mesure que nous avons construit
l'alliance tout ça a toujours été sur la
table ce qui porte ce message vous les
connaissez honnêtement est-ce que ça
peut avoir un quelconque crédit
merci à une question d'actualité
hervé morin vous avez parlé des élus
locaux qui s'inquiète tous aujourd'hui
de l'éventuelle déconfiture faillite ou
démantèlement de la banque dexia qui
financent tous leurs projets d'avenir et
peut faire appel à toutes les banques
aujourd'hui on peut faire appel à toutes
ses banques mais celles ci quand même
celle ci les lignes de crédit celle ci
était notre interlocuteur principal
c'est vrai donc c'est une inquiétude il
ya un sentiment d'urgence quand même ce
qui est vrai michel grossiord ce qui
démontre à quel point les banques ont
resserré les crédits les crédits à
l'économie donc les risques lourds qui
pèsent sur la croissance l'économie
française en 2012
c'est que cette crise de la liquidité
des banques ni collectivités locales la
connaissons déjà parce que je connais
nombre d'élus qui tout en ayant un
budget parfaitement équilibré et une
gestion parfaitement saine on l'a pires
difficultés pour obtenir le financement
lui demande merci pierre antique yol lee
de l' agence france-presse
perrine tarneaud de public sénat va nous
rejoindre pour le dernier quart d'heure
de l'émission juste après ce constat
hervé - les centristes ont au moins un
point de ralliement
le cheval je ne parle pas de celui sur
lequel il convient de miser à l'élection
maintenant mettre du cheval de course
l'a traduit et vous savez pourquoi
parce que parce que le cheval c'est l'
équilibre
le cheval se rééquilibre il est au
centre dans leur position qu'un ticket
politique sur bayrou hervé beau
et jean arthuis partage de points
communs leur appartenance à la grande
famille centriste et leur amour des
chevaux de course
quel est donc ce mystère d'une passion
partagée un sac typique qui serait aussi
politique
françois bayrou dans son béarn élève des
poules un top noir et casaque orange la
couleur du modem jean arthuis le
président de l'alliance centriste aime
par dessus tout sa promenade à cheval du
dimanche matin
quant au président du nouveau centre il
a su déceler dans un poulain au petit
origine l'un des meilleurs chevaux
européen de 2007 gagnant au passage une
petite fortune 2007 une année faste pour
hervé morin en politique la même année
avec nicolas sarkozy il avait déjà misé
sur le bon cheval à court terme du moins
lui qui a gagné le ministère de la
défense dans le sillage la
présidentielle c'est aujourd'hui éloigné
la majorité pour gagner les rangs des
centristes poil à gratter
mais il n'est pas le seul dans la
compétition rivaux se partagent en
espace complexe et mouvant du centre
françois bayrou comme son ex lieutenant
hervé morin bataille déjà dur pour une
place d'honneur dans le grand prix de la
présidentielle dans la grande famille
centriste impossible à fédérer l'un
françois bayrou s'est cabré contre ceux
qui ont pactisé avec nicolas sarkozy
l'autre hervé morin serait aujourd'hui
en chef d'equipe de l'alliance
républicaine écologiste et sociale
maintenant que jean louis borloo a jeté
l éponge c'est tactique tenté de se
façonner l'image de l'alternative entre
livre anti sarkozyste et tour de france
depuis un an
bref pour gagner au jeu des petits
chevaux du centre pas de place pour le
hasard
il va falloir être stratège pour occuper
le créneau de l'autre et renvoyé le
dangereux concurrent à l'écurie
bonjour aussi aux petits chevaux non non
non mon petit les deux mais de mes deux
enfants les plus grands ont passé l'âge
des petits shows les plus petits hervé
morin vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure
que pas grand chose ne pourrait vous
faire renoncer à la présidentielle on a
vu jean louis borloo qui donc a jeté
l'épongé à cause de pressions des
attaques
est ce que vous pensez avoir le cuir
plus épais que lui j'ai hérité ça de ma
mère vous voyez qui est morte ya deux
ans ma mère avait une immense volonté
rien ne la faisait des tournées de
changement mais vous n'avez aucune
expérience de la campagne présidentielle
et celle de 2012 s'annonce quand même
très fort qui a déjà beaucoup d' attaque
comment vous préparez lire mais vous
savez j'ai je suis peu sensible quoi je
me suis dit d'une part voilà
progressivement une armure s'est faite
parce que sinon vous ne vivez pas en
politique mais s'est faite de part votre
expérience
halime ggg une enfin bon c'est sûr
difficile par m mais alors il va falloir
vous lâcher un peu
j'ai mes racines paysannes profonde qui
était d'ailleurs un des points que je
partageais avec françois bayrou font que
j'ai à la fois beaucoup de lucidité
vous n'avez pas oublié de vous venez je
vous reviens pas
voilà mon père un certificat d'études il
était maçon de la créer sa petite
entreprise ma mère comme beaucoup de
deux femmes deux patrons de pme était à
la comptabilité au secrétariat et j'ai
toujours su garder les pieds sur terre
je me suis jamais emballé en plus je
suis normand donc j'ai pas le g on a
toujours un peu de raison garder et de
recul est-ce que ça va suffire tout ça
et on entreprit de l'elysée dire en
début de semaine on va pas lui lâcher
les mollets et deuxièmement
mes racines paysannes font que avant de
dessouder il faut y mettre de la bonne
volonté je peux vous lire on parle et
d'armures
donc c'est pour se protéger l'outil pour
se protéger des coups mais aidé à la
construit ça n'empêche pas d'en donner
aussi passionnante j'ai pas de problème
pour en donner
non mais en données hors données au sens
de faire savoir clairement voilà mais je
ne suis pas du tout dans le et
saloperies c'est pas pour moi mais
finalement toujours le ballon était
encore dans la course si vous servez un
peu de boucliers non ça est plutôt
maintenant non je pense que là il ya une
c'est une nouvelle étape les une
campagne présidentielle ce sont des
temps il ya eu le temps strauss kahn est
au sein des centristes
vous savez vous avez dû m'interroger au
moins cinq fois en dix ans en me posant
cette question est-ce que qu'est-ce qui
fera goudé partageraient entre
jean-louis borloo et vous même et je
vous disais les choses finiront par se
décanter d'elle-même lorsqu'elle est
moment de vérité et chose qui se décante
je pense que ce chemin là vous amène à
un moment être sur la ligne de départ ou
non
alors justement nier les français ont de
vous un peu une image dilettante
comment leur faire voir aujourd'hui et
la bête politique derrière le sourire
que vous affichez qui est agréable mais
ça suffit pas forcément très gentil mais
j'ai je voudrais simplement dire aux
français que j'ai géré un ministère
régalien de première importance
quel ministère de la défense j'ai
effectué une réforme du ministère qui
est une des réformes les plus accomplis
et les plus achevés qu'ils soient nombre
de militaires me disais que c'était la
réforme la plus importante depuis le 19e
siècle et cette réforme elle s'est faite
avec une volonté de chaque instant de
réduire la dépense publique de
fonctionnement pour permettre
l'équipement des forces et
l'amélioration de la condition du
personnel j'ai fait une réforme dont on
disait elle va provoquer la jacquerie de
tous les élus de france vous aurez
observé que fermer une base aérienne où
un régiment de l'armée terre qui
représente des deals des dizaines de
millions d'euros de retombées
économiques dans une commune a fait
moins de bruit que la fermeture d'un
tribunal d'instance
j'ai été en mesure de porter cette
réforme sans que vous n'en parlez plus
de 24 heures dans les journaux
parce que j'ai mis aux normes et
méthodes sans accroche à mélanger mille
objets voiliers devraient en parler de
deux minutes
tous mes collaborateurs quand on a
engagé cette réforme on dit monsieur le
ministre on la présentera à l'été comme
ça comme les réformes précédentes du
ministère la défense
j'avais vécu les précédentes et je
savais comment ça se passait j'ai dit
non on va faire autrement on va faire le
pari de l'intelligence et du partage
d'une même conviction et donc j'ai vu
pendant des mois les élus je les aurai à
la fois expliqué pourquoi le ministère
de la défense devait bouger pourquoi il
fallait supprimer des structures
intermédiaires pourquoi il fallait
mutualiser mettre en commun regrouper et
pourquoi nous avions besoin de faire
évoluer notre titre défense
cette conviction étant partagés nous
avons ensuite site par site démontré un
la pertinence de la décision et 2
démontrer à quel point nous serions
reconstruire ensemble un projet de
reconversion
ce qui fait que quand on me parle de
dilettantisme
ça m'amuse beaucoup parce que cette
réforme je les monnaies et je les mener
à bien
je prends un deuxième exemple vie je
suis profondément c'est fini vous avez
certes réussi à faire passer cette
réforme mais comment se fait-il que
finalement sur les dernières années
quand on parle milliards la défense
retient surtout le nom de michèle alliot
marie au ciel qui a marqué l'essai chez
les moins de vous le dire ça c'est dans
pour ceux qui connaissent pas très bien
la communauté militaire nous parce
qu'ils ont d'eux parce que nous - de
vous parce que je pense que les
aujourd'hui la communauté militaire
parfaitement conscience que j'ai
engagées durant ces trois ans une
réforme qui est absolument indispensable
je vous rappelle pour être désagréable
que lorsque je suis arrivé au ministère
il manquait cinq milliards d'euros pour
but boucler le budget des ménages elle
est passée avec un héritage on avait
engagé toute une série programme qu'on
était incapable de financer
j'ai remis en place tout ça et j'ai
sauvé des programmes qui suis
profondément européen
on m'avait expliqué que l'a400m c'était
cuit j'ai fait le tour des capitales
européennes et j'ai convaincu ministre
par ministre du sauvetage ce programme
qui permet à l'europe de continuer
d'avoir un équipement militaire de
premier plan construit en france et en
europe
troisième sujet
et je dis toujours si tu apprenais après
6,6 après change de thème
ouais l'indemnisation des victimes des
essais nucléaires
c'est moi qui ai porté ce projet là
pendant des décennies la france a refusé
de regarder les choses face à des lobbys
pas forcément très facile j'ai obtenu
cela du gouvernement bat coûté c'est pas
exactement ça marche dans les deux sens
et sur votre bilan au ministère de la
défense nous mettrait bien vous l'avez
défendu pour venir à la présidentielle
vous annoncer d'avancées votre
ralliement au candidat de la droite au
second tour est ce qu'il n'ya pas une
contradiction avec vos critiques très
virulentes de nicolas sarkozy j'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure à votre confrère
que pour moi c'était pas un aliment de
personnes s'était au contraire
à travers cette candidature l'idée
d'être les garants et les gardiens d'un
certain nombre de valeurs de projets et
de mesures présenté aux français
c'est en quelque sorte l'idée simple que
notre soutien est conditionné à un
engagement candidats du second tour à
soutenir un certain nombre de réformes
livre je prends pas réglé il ya quelques
mois je vous laisse finir après quand
par exemple tout à l'heure j'ai évoqué
la république irréprochable pour moi ça
doit faire partie des engagements du
candidat du second tour mais dans votre
livre fut comme la tva sociale par
exemple dans votre lit publiée à
quelques mois arrêtez de mépriser les
français chez flammarion
vous êtes très dur avec nicolas sarkozy
et vous pourriez figurer avec vous sur
la photo du deuxième tour j'avais vu par
je ne je je je pense mais vraiment
intimement que cette pré cette
présidentielle quoi cette législature où
ce mandat pardon et amanda dont la forme
a beaucoup gâté le fond et d'ailleurs
c'est tellement vrai que vous aurez
observer que le président république a
beaucoup changé dans son comportement
depuis huit mois
en quelque sorte ce que je décrivais
mémoire est déjà finie passé que je
décrivais mois il a du fil
me reparlent entendre puisque tout le
monde s'accorde à reconnaître qu'il n'a
plus exactement le même comportement le
mois j'appelais à la sobriété de la
parole à la sobriété du gs à la sobriété
de l'exercice aujourd'hui que briand
république est aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
dans ce dans ce mode là vous avez
compris en tous les cas comme ministre
qu'il fallait jouer le rapport de force
avec le chef de l'état pour se faire
respecter
j'ai toujours entendu ce message là
c'est que l'existence précède l'essence
alors avons pas des militaires à la
danse dans le livre justement on
s'aperçoit qu'ils vous ont poussé quand
même à vous ressaisir là on oublie un
peu le bilan vous avez rappelé flatteur
dans le comportement et il est temps d y
trouver un peu relâché
michel confirme moi je suis pas né sous
les ors de la république personne fait
raconter comment vous a appris à faire
le permet sinon forcément les anticipe
une défaite judo 15h20 enfin je chaud
que je veux dire par là c'est que moi ma
vie a été une construction
je vous sais que j'ai encore en souvenir
une chose c'est le jour où j'ai réussi
un beau concours de la république qui
est d'être le concours d'administrateur
des services de l'assemblée nationale et
quand il est le grand oral en sortant du
grand oral et la douzaine de personnes
qui étaient là
l'un s'est exprimé avant même que je ne
franchissent la porte et en disant il
est pas mal
il va falloir le dégrossir en clair moi
j'ai jamais dîné il met déjeuner durant
mon enfance
ça n'était pas avec des grands patrons
d'industrie des membres du gouvernement
ou la haute fonction publique et donc
chaque période de ma vie a été en effet
une construction
vous êtes toujours en formation
aujourd'hui je pense que j'ai beaucoup
progressé
la formation est terminée mais c'est une
construction permanente j'ai évoqué tout
à l'heure vous ont évoqué tout à l'heure
les critiques que je pouvais mettre sur
l'exercice du pouvoir par le président
de la république vous observer qu'il a
et qu'il a lui aussi évolué et je pense
que c'est tout le monde évolue
vous êtes passé le lieu
vie de françois fillon qui incarne
vraiment à vos yeux l'homme d'état il
pourrait être un recours possible à
droite pensent qu'à pas de recours
possible
aujourd'hui quoi non non je vais va pas
les passer les uns après les autres
si nombreux les audits et des deux là je
pense que aujourd'hui très très
simplement il ya un homme qui est
candidat à sa réélection qui s'appelle
nicolas sarkozy et que tout soit 100 %
des français ne croient pas la
réélection de nicolas sarkozy est ce que
vous en faites partie
je pense que oui sinon je vais sûrement
finir je pense je pense que c'est un
exercice qui sera difficile ça fait
aucun doute
on a une crise sans précédent on
constate que dans tous les pays
européens les majorités sont balayées et
donc très clairement c'est pas
l'élection la plus facile qui nous
arrivent d'autres
dimanche soir josé barroso a évoqué des
coalitions possibles en fonction des
échéances électorales
ce qu'il signifie par là qu'il pourrait
travailler avec la gauche ce que je
crois au delà de cette question c'est
qu'il appartiendra celui qui sera élu
président de la république d'ouvrir
grand les bras
donc on refait l'ouverture non j'allais
vous dira tout sauf l'ouverture c'est à
dire c'est tenter l'équivalent de ce que
sont capables de faire les allemands
c'est à dire la coalition la plus large
possible la même coalition capelle
françois bayrou juge droite
je pense qu'il appartiendra au chef de
l'état de proposer nos pas des hommes
est de proposer des formations
politiques d'appartenir à un même
gouvernement pour tenter de rassembler
le plus largement possible face à la
dureté des temps qui s'annoncent
si grave fraudeur a été capable de
remettre l'allemagne sur le chemin c'est
parce que c'était la grande coalition
que spd et cdo étaient ensemble en tous
les cas vous avez là le même modèle que
françois bayrou là et s'est associé à
leur retour berne exigeantes c'est assez
naturel quand vous avez fait de campagne
avec le même
comment ça va se passer quand nicolas
sarkozy va recevoir les députés nouveau
centre pour les dissuader de vous suivre
comment ça il les reçoit régulièrement
voilà pour le pot pour partager avec eux
avec eux la situation politique du
moment les je pense que le président de
la république ne va pas n'est pas là
pour se livrer à un exercice de ce genre
ce jour il ya les députés centristes
mais aussi les sénateurs centristes quel
rôle vous aimeriez qu'ils jouent dans ce
sénat qui a basculé à gauche il est dit
doivent être ceux qui portent un certain
nombre de propositions politiques qui
sont les nôtres et que nous partageons
quel que soit le parti auquel nous
appartenir qu'il pourrait voter en
fonction des textes à la fois avec la
nouvelle majorité du sénat ou avec
l'opposition ump
lorsque par exemple sur la réduction de
la dépense publique il faudra que nous
soyons en mesure de pouvoir démontrer ce
que nous défendons depuis des années que
nous n'arrivons pas faire entendre à
l'assemblée nationale merci hervé morin
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui merci
perrine bonsoir à tous à la semaine
prochaine